[Musique]
contrat au radiothon titre ou pas encore
frères j'appelle tout de suite je vais
appeler toutes les radios soit 7 de la
daïra d'aflou tu veux virgin radio
tu vas virgin radio j'appelle tout de
suite 0 c'est cyril je suis avec gad
elmaleh
alors j'ai appelé rire et chansons ils
ont pris tous ses sketches à aa
tu sais qu'il a un titre en ce moment
avec dj abdel je tombais bas bidonvilles
tu savais pas tu savais pas été dans la
musique moi tendances évoquées dans la
radio toi tu dois donc faire tiennent
debout ciel t'aidera non non j'ai vu sur
son instinct qui est posté des types de
nougaro frère écoute moi bien
mais telle une leçon comme ça que vous
qu'il sait pas d'origine radio s'apprête
c'est du clavier complet non mais c'est
pas diriger radio je sais que c'est gad
elmaleh je reconnais avoir c'est un ami
est-ce que c'est du virgin radio safran
s'est libéré radio et ben voilà est-ce
que tu me le rendre demain dans la
matinale de manu
on est bien j'appelle régis ravanas
c'est le grand patron de rtl rtl soir qu
à delma ni à mes fils régis comment ça
va c'est cyril hanouna savamment régis
s'embrasser pour moi alors je suis avec
gad elmaleh on en direct il me disait
qu'il aimait beaucoup résisté que gad un
nouveau titre une reprise de claude
nougaro exceptionnel bidonvilles kenyans
son registre
il faut lire entre le mois sur rtl on
supplie une fois au monde dans un bail
comme ça q qu'est ce qu'est ce que tu
veux
jaloux de soi c'est quoi ta taille
adéquate à bayonne on tape de vie bon je
pense que tu veux relief une fois tu ne
mets ces parias pas ok on joue elle
quittera deux crans au fait que je
t'aime et je t'aime encore plus sega
devait être comme un fou donc si tu
aurais tu rentres le titre même une fois
écoute le titre qui fait mal si c'est
une fois c'est pas la peine de savoir
comment ça va régis on a une vraie
histoire l'agression il me suis super
spectacle étonnant c'est que tu es dans
la rue non il me fallait ce thème en
tout cas c'est en tout cas merci passé
le titre ça me touche énormément que tu
t'engages vraiment en direct devant la
france entière apache et le titre
j'invite tous les auditeurs d'rtl
si le titre ne passe pas le réclamer ce
sera simplement un oubli de régis dé
régis va s'engager merci infiniment
parce que dix rotations par heure je
trouve que c'est un gâchis énorme on
applaudit régis ravanas
[Applaudissements]